el conflicto en etiopía ha cobrado
cientos de vidas cientos de familias
cruzan la frontera con lo poco que les
queda son miles los que emprenden un
nuevo rumbo hacia el vecino sudán en
algunos casos a pie una travesía
las fuerzas entraron y quemaron nuestras
casas y mataron a nuestra gente nos
dejaron en la nada ahora voy a sudar
al hayya vamos hace cerca de dos semanas
inició el conflicto entre el gobierno
federal de etiopía y las fuerzas
regionales de tigre en un acto
desafiante y las regiones atacaron con
cohetes a dos aeropuertos de la región
de amar a un ataque que las fuerzas de
tigre insisten que era necesario como ya
hemos dicho antes para poder frustrar la
invasión de tigre nuestra defensa está
tomando medidas proporcionales basados
en esta decisión ayer en la noche
atacamos los bloques militares de los
aeropuertos donde iba a girar ahora
crece el miedo de que el conflicto se
extienda hasta la frontera con eritrea
esto luego de que se reportara que
diplomáticos en la región dijeron que
tres cohetes habían sido lanzados a un
aro
puerto de la capital de eritrea asmara
esto se dio justo después de que el
gobierno regional de tigre advirtiera
sobre un posible ataque en frente de
liberación popular de tigre tiene una
historia tumultuosa con eritrea estaba
en conflicto con el país vecino desde
1998 hasta el año 2000 ahora el grupo
acusa al primer ministro etíope a viaje
de recibir apoyo militar de eritrea algo
que su país rechaza enérgicamente